On June 6th 1944 Allied troops staged
the largest seaborne invasion the world
has ever seen
[Music]
djay helps liberate Europe from the
Nazis but it was also pivotal in
creating a new world order this was
dominated at first by two superpowers
and ultimately by America and heroines
but this liberal Western order is now
under threat in 1941 after two years of
fighting German armies were still
advancing having taken Paris in 1940
they invaded Russia and were pushing
back the British in North Africa later
in the Pacific the Japanese bombed Pearl
Harbor and took Singapore from the
British the world was at war and the
Allies were losing but from the middle
of 1942 the table starts to turn with
wins by the Americans in the Pacific the
British in North Africa and the Russians
on the Eastern Front after a prolonged
siege at Stalingrad the Russians cut off
and crushed the Germans in February 1943
Joseph Stalin the Soviet Union's ruler
had long urged the other allied leaders
Winston Churchill and Franklin D
Roosevelt to open up another front
against the Nazis in the West but it
wasn't until November 1943 that they met
for the first time and laid plans to
invade German occupied France the
Germans knew the invasion would come
they just didn't know precisely when or
where it would take place
the Allies deceived the Germans into
thinking they were going to attack
Calais the closest point to England they
created dummy armies in southeast
England and disseminated false
information to German intelligence but
they surprised the Germans by invading
Normandy instead On June 6th 1944 over
150,000 American Canadian French and
British troops landed on beaches
codenamed Utah Omaha gold Juno and sword
German forces were spread too thinly
along the western coast of Europe and
could not contain the Allies Paris was
liberated by August and the Allies
pressed into Belgium and Holland and
eventually into Germany itself
as the Russians closed in on Berlin from
the East Hitler killed himself and
Germany surrendered in May 1945 less
than a year after d-day after the war
Germany and Europe remained divided by
the Iron Curtain the Soviet Union
controlled the East and America and her
allies the West in 1949 the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization or NATO was
created to protect Western Europe from
the growing Soviet threat with the
backing of America the precursor of the
European Union was formed in 1951 for
around 70 years NATO and the EU have
formed the pillars of Western security
supporting America as the dominant
global force despite the comradeship on
display at anniversary celebrations for
d-day NATO is fraying it's absolutely a
lot of countries aren't paying us what
they should be paying President Donald
Trump has suggested that America may
withdraw from NATO altogether
he's also been critical of the European
Union and has supported Britain's
withdrawal from the EU
the Western order is also being
challenged by an aggressive Russia and
the rise of China
this should be a time for the old allies
to stand together instead 75 years after
fighting and dying together on the
beaches of Normandy they're becoming
more divided
[Music]